it was a star-studded affair on Friday
at the puppy nightclub and Kylie
cosmetic party sponsored by BMW and
Pizza boys radio on beats one Paris
Hilton dance to cardi B's hit and tucked
on the PDA with her fiance Chris Zilka
while Rihanna worked it out
Kylie's sister Kendall Jenner was also
in attendance but an eye witness tells
et the sisters barely hung out instead
Kylie who rocked neon pink tresses
stayed close with boyfriend Travis Scott
our eyewitness says they seemed every
bit the loving couple kissing and
holding hands
ETSI witness also says exes Bella Hadid
and The Weeknd got close hanging out at
a VIP table where they smooched all
night but according to another
eyewitness it wasn't all love all night
Bella apparently didn't have the
greatest time watching her former flames
performance at the Music Festival
earlier that night she didn't stay for
the whole thing she left early with
friends and looked pretty serious in
fact she bolted before he's saying call
out my name which is reportedly about
Selena Gomez
[Music]